im bunker unter der reichskanzlei ist es
inzwischen ganz schön leer geworden er
ist noch da rochus misch gehört zum
sogenannten führer begleitet kommando
des hitler überall hingefallen
obersalzberg nach polen russland und
schließlich in diese soriano bunkern
echt jetzt ab und seine frau und seine
einjährige tochter
das geht nicht so einfach bis wenige
tage vor der kapitulation des
großdeutschen reiches arbeitet er als
telefonistin burg eine aufgabe die ihn
später zu einem der wichtigsten zeugen
aus hitlers umfeld macht 12 00 50
unter dieser nummer ist er dort unten zu
erreichen
telefonzentrale reichskanzler wohnung
seine oberst vettel ist im moment nicht
zu sprechen
ja gehts weiter oder uns bricht der
leyen doch hier sofort zusammen und was
sagt deine frau dazu habe sie immer noch
nicht erreicht im moment komme nach
münchen besser durch als nach rudow was
dies immer noch in berlin hat sich nicht
ausfliegen lassen hat mir in not korea
in die hand gedrückt anschluss
du sagst das alles
telefonzentrale reichskanzler für ihre
wohnung nein herr minister das nicht zu
sprechen wo man nicht mehr hier
general krebs warten sie sich holen
da dachte ich na ja wieder randale
kann sein dass ein geschaffen es war
jedenfalls filialen haben angestoßen und
entdecken wollen keine ahnung wie sie
herr general mark gesehen dass er
deutlich
mit einem kurzen schreck bekommen
aber ich bin noch geblieben weil er
gerne niederlassen hand ich wollte ja
wie die anderen ja auch alle sie wollte
auch wenn aber ich muss ja noch bleiben
ich musste abwarten bis er mich reden
lässt
als das geschafft was ja meine adresse
klar
in meiner frau
momentan ist kann ich nicht machen unser
strom also alles macht gehabt ein
anderer nach der gefangenschaft
aufgesucht
in württemberg und klavier was noch
passiert dass ich weg bin
da hat man auch mit benzin übergossen
und angezündet als zurück was war dann
kurz auch paar minuten marathon
warum es nicht flüchtet in den frühen
morgenstunden des 2 unter beschuss durch
die u bahn schächte berlins wird aber
von der roten armee gefasst der vater
zwangsarbeit in sowjetischen straflager
hätte er es 1954 zu seiner frau